y continúan las tareas de rescate aquí
en la ciudad de surfside colindante a
miami bits y más de 80 equipos de
rescate están trabajando en el lugar
tratando de encontrar supervivientes
entre los escombros entre los amasijos
de hierro y hormigón las autoridades
dicen que estas primeras horas son
cruciales para poder encontrar gente con
vida hasta el momento se han confirmado
4 muertos y 159 personas se han
reportado como desaparecidas son
momentos muy angustiantes también para
los familiares que se están reuniendo en
el centro de reunificación angustiados
con fotografías y también con pruebas de
adn con la esperanza de poder encontrar
y quedar con sus seres queridos en las
autoridades se dicen que ahora no es
momento para las investigaciones que la
prioridad es dar con el máximo número de
supervivientes posibles a pesar de que
aquí nadie entiende cómo es posible que
un edificio
de 12 plantas con más de 130
apartamentos y aparentemente en buen
estado se haya desplomado de la noche a
la mañana era un edificio construido en
1981 este año se cumplían 40 años de esa
construcción y debía pasar una revisión
especial